dancing with the stars alum max
murkowski in the ukrainian capital of
kiev as russia invades ukraine welcome
to entertainment tonight you know we've
seen the reporters putting themselves in
harm's way and the destruction on the
ground meanwhile max is sharing his
intense fears frustrations and
helplessness over a country in crisis
honestly i'm getting really emotional
it's been a little difficult
it's gonna be a bloodshed
i'm somebody who's about to go into a
bomb shelter
because
going down
i will never be the same that's what max
posted amidst the chaos also writing my
old ptsd i finally fixed is coming back
the dancer and choreographer who was
born in ukraine while it was still a
part of the soviet union talked to e.t
about the challenges of leaving as a
teenager i was 14 you know sort of a
already established person i remember a
lot of things immigration and how that
sucked and you know things that we've
overcome
mack's younger brother val was eight
when the family immigrated to brooklyn
ninety percent of the furniture was
furniture we found on sidewalks
like we would drive down i'm gonna get
emotional
before yesterday's invasion the 42 year
old had been working as a judge on the
ukrainian version of world of dance my
family is far away
max has a five-year-old son with wife
peter murgatroyd who's also a dancing
alum she asks for prayers for his safe
return home i have a passport and i have
a way out a lot of people here do not
also in the ukrainian capital sean penn
e.t has learned the outspoken actor is
working on a documentary for vice
studios about the invasion today he
visited the president and attended a
press briefing all this
as reporters scramble oh that's a
missile that's a missile this australian
reporter filmed a russian missile
overhand and cnn's matthew chance put on
a flak jacket and helmet live on the air
and major props to ap reporter philip
crowther there's been a war with
russian-backed forces the journalist has
been stunning viewers with this mashup
reporting from kiev in six languages
english luxembourgish spanish portuguese
french and german in the ukraine
einstein
[Music]